this is a production of Cornell
University
I just love sharing what I know with all
of you and I know we've got growers in
the audience we got graduate students in
the audience we've got garden centers in
the audience we got everything and I and
I'm pleased to be able to do that
somebody will recognize me and I got
heck last night Jeff told me where's my
hat so this is me I am here all right i
am here so so and again i have way too
little time to tell way too many stories
but the fact is that this hat is a whole
lot more important than i am but we got
i gave you a handout which is kind of
fun to do of course boats fit percent of
it you won't even see today but it'd be
a good handle for you anyway and i am
going to talk about veggies as well
because unlike Peter I haven't quite
gotten all the way there but I love
veggies we've been we've been trialing
veggies at the University of Georgia for
all the new what I call patio vegetables
ornamental vegetables my daughter who is
going to get vegetables and doesn't want
to have a vegetable garden my neighbors
who want vegetables but don't want to
make a big deal and so I've been doing
this for some time as well I'll show you
a few things but in the meantime here's
what I'm going to do everybody we talk
forever about how we're going to get
young people and I look at young people
anybody under 50 as a young person into
this hood of his game and everybody and
I mean everybody is using a cell phone
smartphone to do things by my son who's
way too old living in San Francisco and
he doesn't move a muscle without doing
this little thing whether it's an uber
or a restaurant or a review and so why
don't we do something about what we do
on the smartphone I mean if you look to
try and find information on the web you
can find a ton of things but you got to
be sitting on the web okay so you go to
your phone go to the webinars a ton of
things a ton of different places why
don't we find a place that works so I
have developed this for what it's worth
and if it's if it works bill we will see
if this thing actually happens and if it
doesn't happen I
really giving you a great haha so this
is a cell phone on the right you can see
an app called Armitage okay I have
developed an app for you for gardeners
landscapers garden centers anybody who
touches plants all right and it is an
app that I developed for my neighbors
and my daughter's people not like you
know something but people who want to
know something and they don't want it so
complicated I can't figure out what to
do so if you do this and this is totally
up to you there's about 10,000 on this
thing right now if you do this you just
go to your and this is right now and I
really hesitate to say this right now
the new version what you're looking at
is on the iphone and ipad it will be on
the android hopefully by next week but
if you have an Android you want to do it
wait all right just wait for a week or
so because the new version is much
better than the old one having said that
if you want to do about your App Store
search armitage and this will come right
up it's called dr. raise greatest
perennials and annuals and I guess going
to demonstrate this wrote five minutes
and then we'll get into the talk so if
you hit this thing ok it comes up here
and then it comes up to this screen so
this is your iphone screen or your iPad
which is really spectacular by the way
it says everything up there and there's
all sorts of stuff there's there's
there's a ton of things but let me go to
the ton of things that you're interested
in like every single plant that you sell
and I'm saying you sell you breed you
work with is on here so and reels and
perennials and whatever here's angelonia
for example i'm just going to this is a
good place to start as any if you hit
this ok it comes up and it's real simple
its common name every single plant has a
deer browsing rating meaning so in other
words if you hit this it says three and
it comes up and it says one two three
four or five is it is it a hosta or is
it something that they're not going to
get really touch now dear will he eat
anything we know this but having done
all the research on this it's the best I
can do also on here there's a rabbit
browsing the same thing Heights etc so
it's real self
and you can see it says why it makes my
cut sorry gang it's my app so like it or
don't like it and I tell you why I think
it's a good plant and you know believe
it or not actually a few people actually
think i know what i'm talking about so
it's it's good hints for success for my
neighbor for your neighbor it's its Sun
as its shade is it what's it need etc
and then the neat thing is my top
choices so these are the varieties are
the cultivars that you're probably
selling anyway having said all that
people like pictures so if I can do this
picture right here I can then do this
picture and it's going to take a little
bit of time but there's there's about 12
different pictures of Angeloni on here
which I can see is not going to happen
but anyway we'll go back hold on maybe
maybe if I do it this way anyway all
these little dots up there each one is a
different photograph and most of them
are the ones that I am recommending so
you have photos you have information you
have something it's really simple but
let me show you something else so any
plan is in here I mean we could have fun
with this there's videos on here where
I'm yapping about something there's a
lots of goodies let me show you a couple
of other things if I go over here this
says plants so you can do annuals or
perennials or natives or grasses you can
go all the way down to a usda zone
you're in ok so you can do all that kind
of stuff and that's fun but if I also go
over here I hit garden centers now I I
know the sewer marg atoms are here
somewhere and i know that i wrote a
bunch of you if there's any garden
center people in the audience and if i
wrote you and you ignored me so be it
but you can get listed on this app free
of charge so these are people in in the
area there were 200 miles in the area
but so here's Adams there in Kingston
their new burger Poughkeepsie and
they're in wappinger waban girl whatever
anyway so if I hit this thing what
happens on any garden center if you know
a good garden center and these are good
garden centers I'm not going to internet
and grabbing them I'm writing them based
on recommendations or they write me so
it says okay here's Adams Ferris in
Kingston this is something that sue sent
me or whatever okay that's cool phone
number
can call them the global thing that's
their website I won't hit it because
it's just real slow in here and the
other thing up here and again I'll hit
it but I want to want to work is go go
google maps so google maps will take you
right there wherever you're standing so
any garden center in the country who
wants to get on here gets listed free of
charge and what it costs them is to tell
their people that they're on the app but
they're on the app so why wouldn't they
tell them anyway and the last thing I'm
going to show you is things that I
believe in there's birds and butterflies
so everybody who's in a sustainable
thing you'd like this there's a couple
of good books I like ground covers I
work with HGTV here's some thoughts on
plant food you know this is
recommendation of my daughters and
others too little time and too little
money nobody fertilizes plants you know
we talked about it but they don't
fertilize a lot so we found something
and I work with a really key cool cuff
and it's out here and this cool company
is called nature source and anyway so if
it says a plant food it says how to get
it it says what stores are doing it
right here and the cool thing again and
unfortunately probably oh good I took
some photos just this has done to
Cornell this is done in the greenhouses
yesterday with nature source vs. not
nature so that again I'm not selling it
I don't do whatever you want but I'm
just showing it this is what I believe
in and so on I believe in something I
like to tell the world so there's one on
the right with nature source on the left
with something else and there's a whole
slew of these things that we can show
but nevertheless so this is what this
app does it is for and I tell you who's
really using it or the staff of garden
centers they can go behind a pole I can
check it out and can I guess there how
can I help you so so anyway I wanted to
show you that because that is truly a
trend if there is one trend in this
world it is a smartphone and the trend
that we have never even taken advantage
of at all I mean I mean horticulture
magazine has their thing and we probably
all have a little thing here and there
but what are your neighbor have you know
I get high with wish they would buy all
my books and Holliman are not going to
so my daughter for sure well by one of
my books so the thing is that's what
this is all about so if you want if
you're interested have fun if your
garden center let me know i'll certainly
put you on if anybody needs a card and
stuff
we'll do it so that that's the app and I
wanted shorter now we're going to get
into something else assuming we can make
this work so you have a handout and
again I'll never get through all this
stuff so they don't worry about it we'll
do the best we can I've already taken a
bunch of stuff off you know I'm lugging
a mark and Sue here I know they're going
to carry much of this stuff I work with
so many different people i work with a
pro a place called the perennial far
more over the nature source people I'll
Newsome is here with this good dirt
which is going to be a great product for
you guys coming down the road I work
with HDTV so they have any questions and
all that stuff I certainly worked with a
cut flower people and I can't wait to
hear what Chris has to say so it's good
and of course I've always I've often
been speaking with Marjorie and its
really good to speak with Marjorie
because I know I have pretty stuff and
Marjorie comes in and boy my stuff looks
awful after she's done with it so well
so anyway how can we keep up with us to
hodda we do it there's so much material
I mean digi plexus what the hell is digi
plexus I'll ampro kapnos and my no one
went pro cap noses thigh sentra they
changed the name okay so you're going to
be seeing die you know die sent respect
opolis the great big beautiful bleeding
heart is now listen who cares but the
fact is it's there and I mean let's see
if there's this thing working maybe this
is merc know and are we really serious i
think truly is there such a thing as a
ketchup and fries plant are we really
gone that far down the road so here we
go anyway this is plants that I and I
talk about plants a lot i talk about
marketing a lot of how about anything
you want me to talk but unfortunately
but this is in front of stores in a
little town in Canada called
niagara-on-the-lake if you get to nag on
the lake you'll understand why plants
make a difference this town and many
other towns I know I'm in Cooperstown as
fabulous too they plant plants because
they know in front of stores that people
are more comfortable when there's
around they know that and they'll spend
more money it's a simple thing so we can
do you know we can beautify America we
have programs to certainly help towns
and all do beautification just plant
some plants and if you're a grower give
plants away to stores help them to do it
this is how we get it done you know as
much work it is to sell plants and
customers simply want to have fun
remember that I don't care how serious
you get their customer is not serious so
serious about spending money but they do
it for therapy and they do it for the
beauty they don't have that same kind of
like in those guys and in general I mean
you know I mean you've got these master
gardeners it'll knock your head off
absolutely without a doubt but the fact
is people buy plants for therapy it
makes them feel good quite truthfully
and and and keep them happy don't take
yourself seriously like goodness you
take yourself seriously you would just
have no friends whatsoever because this
is who we are okay come on let's just
get ourselves under don't take me
seriously I can tell you a bunch of
stuff because I think this is my hundred
years in in practice here has shown me
what I think are great plan so that
people want to do but you're you're
going to walk with here hopefully with
two plants out of all these so it says
American horticulture gardening have
come a long way but gang just in case
you're wondering let's not get ourselves
too carried away we still have a long
way to go we really do but this was cool
because there were three new guinea
impatience this year and next year we
are hoping for six if we could double
the number of plants and person buys we
ever be in pretty good shape wouldn't we
but we have come a long way we really
have and where do you see what that with
Kendra and group have done this
afternoon it's really neat the plants
that are out there but we're going to
start with these off the line creatures
we're going to start today with annuals
okay and angles really are maligned you
know there's so many plants knobs out
there and they certainly wouldn't
wouldn't buy annuals oh my goodness now
those of you who are in the garden
center business and in the petunia trade
and a calibrachoa tray we know how
important these are for landscapers are
no important they are for those people
want to beautify properties but you know
angles a geranium a miracle you I'd be
kidding but it is it is so fabulous what
has gone on out here and the breeding
has been nothing short of spectacular
you're going to see some of that this
afternoon as well so I'm just going to
start taking you through a merry little
tour of some of the plants that I think
are terrific and again I don't have a
lot of time so if I do speed up please
yes i'm in North Country now so you can
raise your hand and I can say yes if you
don't know something shoot the puck let
me know all right shoot apart can't do
that Georgia rule will you can old
Canuck that's all we used to do so it's
early i hope you're ready because it is
time to start the engines this is where
your your handout starts and if you see
anything you want to take a look at
please feel free angelonia and again
I've really cold this list down again I
do talks and annuals at last I horse
really boring but angelonia called angel
flower called summer Snapdragon whatever
you want to do it's a plant that
tolerate you know you've had a nice
relatively cool summer lots of rain here
I know the assembly and joins look
pretty good at the trials of if you get
a summer where it's warmer and you get a
summer where's dryer this is a fabulous
plant and what I I think and I've told
all my students and I think all of you
understand even though my daughter will
come in and she won't have a clue what a
cultivar is it's a cult of our world I
don't even know what the specie of this
looks like anymore so we live in a cult
of our world so you should know and it
gets really are there any other any
retailers here okay well you guys are
where the rubber hits the road you must
understand this that when your neighbor
comes in to your store and looks or
something they're not going to ask for
carita angelonia but if you realize or
you know because you've walked around
you've looked around you studied you've
maybe even believe me but this is a good
series then you sell them that because
if you're not coming into your store
because they don't like you they're
coming into your store because they
trust you and you don't have to sell
them a cult of our name but you have to
sell in a good cultivar
because nobody comes into your store
today nobody and says hey Mark what's
old right nobody says that and they come
in they say what's new they go they'll
all know what's new well what's new to
you my daughter's going to see for five
years all right so what's new is really
means what what do you got that's good
and so anyway so enough of that that
that's this one that I think is a
terrific there's another series out
there the Sarah need is which are a
little shorter the whole short and
compact thing we really kind of like is
an industry because we can ship them
easier we don't have to maintain quite
as much in the landscape they're
generally better bright better braking
and they're just as easy to grow so this
is pink and there's other colors as well
Archangel dark rose these are all on
your hand oh by the way so just you know
we need different colors so I picked a
few from this and the other thing that
is really happening today to the garden
of today and certainly the garden of
tomorrow without a doubt is the deck
okay absolutely that means containers
baskets and what you see from the deck
so you can have a garden I don't mean to
say to me no gardens but containers and
baskets are becoming more important not
just because well they're kind of fun
what else are we going to do with a
bacopa I mean what else going to do
throw in a container because it nobody
else would have it otherwise but the
fact is you know a lot of these plants
have been bred to fall out of baskets to
fall out of containers and that's a good
thing so these spreading ones I think
are good there's even spreading roses
you might know that actually are
designed for baskets so this is a trend
to be sure you know somebody asked me
once how how big is that deck going to
be as pretty simple as large as the
Wi-Fi signal reaches I mean solely
that's where we are so anyway begonias
you know again that's sort of a bonilla
kind of like oh my god a begonia but the
fact is wax begonias are almost
indestructible you know and when you're
working with people that really don't
and I said any landscapers here well
a few of you I won't say anything
terribly bad but but you know
landscapers are a great group and they
really do enhance properties and all but
a lot really don't know a whole lot
about plants and so what you do is you
make sure they have plants that are not
going they're going to succeed with the
begonias are just a great success plan
certainly the wax begonias I like the
big series right now they've been really
working on it this is a Benari product
out of Germany and they it looks really
good it's a big plant and gardeners love
it landscapers can fill in a lot of room
with it the dragon wings I mean good
grief or whether for dragon wings we
wouldn't have the bonus today now
they're all to be sure but there's still
a fabulous seller and here it is with
our damn easy on the ground we know they
work in the baskets we know they work
just what anywhere in fact on the app
under begonias I made a special thing
for dragon wings because it's so
important but what else is happening
well this is what's happening and you'll
see some in the garden this afternoon
the pendulum of bolivian sis types but
don't you worry about that but the
penniless forms of begonias and there's
Santa Cruz and I'm going to mention
cultivars remember that and you should
know a little bit about cultivars now as
a consumer you don't care but as a
certainly a person in the plant world
you should Santa Cruz is a good one and
I've trialed everyone known to man and
then I think probably kandra's going to
be trialing a lot more this is the
newest called San Francisco and again
another binary product but you can see
how pendulums are now this is going in
California okay big deal I can put this
in George it's not going to look as good
as still go look pretty darn fine and
certainly nothing in New York this is
going to look terrific so this is the
newest one if you're interested and and
then you can see this other new group
that I think is this fabulousness this
comes out of a place called now
digitalis but anyway this is bossa nova
series so there's the Santa Cruz in San
Francisco group and then the bossa nova
group that i think are terrific now
there's lots of others but there's
something you can take a look at maybe
try one or two of these if you like them
any questions
if I have but one plant to put in front
of my store or one plant to put you know
on the door the doorway going into the
house it would probably some of these
new Rex hybrids not because of any
better than the others but they just
have that look that people just love so
here's Jurassic is a new group out of
well it's out of out of ball and then
Shadow King is out of green fuse both
breeders in this country and it's kind
of cool but the Jurassic one has gone
crazy they've run out of they run out of
plant material long before they ran out
of people who wanted them and the Shadow
King is just just finding its mark right
now but these are all these are all che
plants for foliage they don't flower
with a darn but boy do they make a
splash and they're easy to grow they're
just easy so give them something they
want they're going to spend the money
give them something that they're going
to be happy with parting with their
dollars i put in can is because you know
this tropical look as another trend it's
been a trend with us a long time you
know there's been a fad in a trend five
years so to speak you know fab last
three years or so a trend last five plus
years and maybe continues forever but
trend has to stop being a trend of being
real world and this is real world the
tropical look as real world whether it's
a taro or whether it's a canna it
doesn't I mean every annual is a
tropical and patience is tropical but
it's a tropical look that many of us are
after so this is in Montreal you should
have ahead and canna and this is a this
is a wasabi coleus at the Botanical
Garden Montreal to have a chance to get
up there boy is it spectacular place to
go and anyway so there's a can of pretty
far north so we don't have to be in a
south to grow these things I know that
ken is working with cannas there's a lot
of fabulous Canada's the foliage on
Canada's can be really quite exciting
and of course the dark forms like
Australia which has been out for a
little bit but you pull Australian
remember most Candice today now are
grown from seed because there's a well
as margarine all those big virus
problems with Canada's and all that are
propagated vegetatively so if you cannot
get as a
roller you cannot get your material from
seed I'd be real careful about putting
it out there so the newest seed stuff
are these two this is a the one on the
top is canova and again another ball
product the terrific product there's a
mix i was at georgia trials there came
out this year and then this new one can
us all from let's say syngenta is coming
out next year there's a group this one's
called CLE over there's a whole group of
them coming out these are all bred to be
short okay I mean short meaning no
higher than no I'll say three feet but
you know give or take you're going to be
shorter here than we are in Georgia
right oh there they look good there are
diseases disease hardly any disease to
speak of whatsoever and so two new
groups from which to choose and again I
guess through this in because I thought
this was really cool it looked like a
bird of paradise was actually a can of
called bird of paradise so I thought I
just stuck that outside that went
outside the drive out is really cool is
it's too weird to ignore but speaking of
a little weird you know what we need
plants every now and then that people
talk about and we hope that they're as
good as the hype but we need plants that
people talk about and they are talking
about this thing digi plexus now for
those of you and of course we're here
the endemic enviros of Cornell
University you know that this is a this
is a very interesting inter generic
hybrid at least that's what they thought
it was this is a cross between digitalis
that we know and a plan from the Canary
Islands called ISIL plexus i supply i
know and and and so they called digi
plexus now digi plexus is a common name
only botanically it is now digitalis
okay botanically it is a digitalis
hybrid but the fact is this digi plexus
people kind of think this is neat and it
is neat plant as long
long as the retailers understand it is
an annual now certainly should be pretty
easy to understand in Cornell but their
silliness is an annual even in Atlanta
and it excuse me as a perennial even in
Atlanta it is not the Canary Islands are
not exactly the perennial capital of the
world so but it's cool anyway so people
are talking about it is a fabulous
annual it will continue to flower if you
cut back to full or the cut back the
spent flowers and there's a lot of
breeding being done on it this is
illumination flame was the first one but
there's three or four new ones coming
out very canary and a couple of others
it is I think it's got a three year
three to five year lifespan so getting
it now I just don't think it's going to
hang in there for a long period of time
even though they're going to continue
it's got some issues and certainly I
don't know if Marjorie look at it it's
got some disease issues for sure it is
not a digitalis as we think of a
digitalis so just be careful call it
dizzy plexus and you'll sell a ton to
call it and make it an annual and you
will do just fine and getting people
getting exciting I think that's a cool
thing I don't I don't I don't think I
can stand anymore sonals Ives or told
myself to death I trialed I tried we
started the University of Georgia trials
when 1983 82 been gone for a long time
and we've trial probably a hundred
different geraniums almost every year
and how has hired students that was the
best part of the whole garden I hired
students to take care of things deadhead
zones in August in Georgia you have a
tough student all my students were very
easily employable believe me they
learned out of work but I mean they're
they're terrific and I mean they're not
going to go away and there's a zillion
em out there whether it's Patriots or
lures or whatever but this is of course
what's happening the what's happening
again back to the basket container thing
the the hybrids between the zonal and
the IV's that's been happening in the
last five years and Kellyanne t is one
that I think most of us can rely on and
you don't know what timeless is it's a
cali auntie with a new name the company
that put out timeless simply bought that
breeding and it's exactly the same thing
so that's what's happening i think the
IV's
are just spectacular the real
improvements in geranium of the hybrids
and the IV's and you're going to see a
lot more of those but there's also all
sorts of you know scented geraniums and
color geraniums and we'll see some of
the trial I know we saw some last night
at that plantation the variegated
geraniums are all cool but again for the
landscaper for the person it really
wants a plant that's going to last all
summer and really make a show I think
this is where we're at my opinion I
mentioned last night that if I did it
planting for a dormitory like I sorry
dormitory or horas aura or eternity I
would use Lantana's and gomphrena so
anak student fell out the window they
would land on a lantana and no damage
would be done to either my antennas are
tough but so are gone freenas and these
are what you put in is parking lots this
is what you'll use in a median and a
roadway that gone friends are just tough
as nails and then you put Canada's and
gone freenas and everything look out
Lantana's and go fetus so Las Vegas are
short they're wonderful they do they do
well there's and that note the old gnome
series this is much better and again
there's of Las Vegas purple in Las Vegas
pink in Las Vegas weight and then this
is the one I think is really wonderful
if you have a gardener on your clientele
or a landscaper as opposed to somebody
just wants to throw color out there this
this is almost waist high and this is
fireworks and I think it's just a finest
conferring out there but you're not
going to stick hundreds of out there you
know this is a garden plant or a
landscape plant and I think it's
wonderful so that's again my take on
gomphrena except for this thing and I
won't know how many people have tried it
we tried this and we are we are we done
pink zazzle anybody okay Pink's hassles
now out there ok it was out there last
year in little limited things that's
been out there this year we bit for
again those garden centers or growers or
somebody want to try something different
it looks terrific it's just whether
tolerance is the issue in cornell here i
think in New York may be fabulous it
gets
little tough when it gets 24 hour south
but for you guys and maybe for terrific
and people like it that you don't like
it or hate it you know I I won't tell
too many stories but i'm from montreal
i'm from way the heck up there i'm in
georgia now okay and they keep saying
that the Canadians keep saying I are so
lucky must be so much fun to garden
almost year-round oh you know we do have
winter but it's still a long guarding
season and then they complain that they
can't grow this and can't grow that it's
too cold for this nicole for that and I
look at them like they're crazy it is so
much easier to garden in the North and
the South so much easier because in the
north it's either very pretty or dead
okay i mean it's it's there's there's
really no middle ground like it is south
its other's languages it hangs in there
you know and you don't want to cut it
because it's there but it is so much i
just spent a week in maine I mean it is
fabulous everything was fabulous so so
this may do very very well for you and
give it a go well this is from our jury
of course this is Marjorie slides thank
you one of these these are on the and
for your your book and easier on this is
on the app by the way Marjorie so downy
mildew is not a problem give thanks you
know and and you know there's a
gazillion beddings as you know I don't
know I assume it's a problem here in
this area okay so you're probably not
selling much if I'm knowing not a whole
lot of people selling them or buying
them or whatever so you know that's the
same picture than Marjorie sent me and
and no it's a huge problem in here is
and you know I don't know if you'll
agree with me Marjorie but what I see is
the good news it doesn't seem to be
getting a whole lot worse but we still
have lots of problems so is there any
help coming with this thing and and and
whoops the good news is that there is
help coming you know we have margarine I
think you're probably talk about this
little bit about what's going on or
whatever James in here graduate student
James Roy he's working on the breeding
to breed a downy mildew out of this
thing I can hardly wait to see what you
get so watch this kid he's going to be a
star and
so there is help coming but what do we
got today we know that the new guineas
aren't susceptible we know that we can
throw in the guineas but new guineas
aren't betting patients are just not
they're more expensive though they're
just they're just not they don't take
shade as well but you know that's okay
certainly the Sun patients of Sun
harmony won't work in a shady area very
well by 10 0 what do we need now well
lady Marjorie waiting larger E and we
need James and we need all the people
involved in this problem because boy oh
boy I don't have to tell you what a huge
problem this has become I mean a number
one ornamental seed plant in the world
in five years con and so we need help
and and and the help is going to be from
breeding there's absolutely 0 doubt
about it will make sprays in this now
because this is a decent plan i'm
showing you this not because i'm selling
bounce me because i think this is as
good as what we have at the moment to
replace those bending and patience lots
of brakes on bounce low growing lots of
flowers and shade tolerant so I again it
is what it is we had better bergoglio's
we need we need better shade material we
need lots of lots of things and we have
lots of things you just got to try them
but for those beds where you want to
have a lot of color and you have partial
shade this might be one and again i wish
i was going to penny for every one i
sold but I'm not okay what am I going to
go to do ok no more than good ok alright
sweet alyssum vast and frozen start with
snow princess there's a variegated one
is really ugly down there White Knight
don't buy it but nevertheless it's there
but this is a snow princess was the
beginning of it all and if you were an
old codger like me you remember sweet
alyssum mean eight they just didn't last
the summer they did they did it they
just didn't have the bigger they didn't
have anything and it's certainly going
to heat on them forget it but now we
have some terrific clients i think the
stream series is extraordinary
this is lavender stream in a basket and
here's lavender stream in the ground and
here's white stream over here as well so
I think that's a good one there's yolo's
come out just recently it's a new one
with a really good white so the LOB
Galleria's or whatever this thing is now
already quite good and I have to show
you this because while I showed you some
pretty pretty pictures really lovely
stuff we really do have to understand
there's some dogs out there I mean this
is ugly as sin as far as I'm concerned
but they're selling it as Tom Tom or
told him or something so as I was with
my friend and we were we were
disparaging this really ugly plant we
know that plants can't read we decided
out yesterday that plants can't read we
put them in areas that we shouldn't
Courtney the books most books that is
and they do just fine so as we were
saying these terrible things are not
sure that plants can't hear because as
we were walking away it was saying it
was number one
always have fun with this stuff always
have fun you know truly do not take any
of this stuff seriously because this is
like people love this stuff so you know
whether whether they can hear or not who
knows but it's fun it really is fun I'll
just finish off this annual thing with a
few terrific rudbeckia is I think the
tiger eyes are extraordinary denver
daisy has been a real good one from osu
a big flower seems to do well and the
Prairie son just won't go away it's just
a good plan so the annual Rebecca's are
really quite terrific really quite
terrific the ornamental foliage ones
such as alternate there's ma'am and this
foliage is where it's at right now
here's Brazilian red hot but if you have
one plant to buy for foliage for your
landscapers get this one this is little
Ruby it is it is low growing it's not
more than six to eight inches tall it
stays that color all season and it is
just that the extraordinary plan and
it's an alternate IRA copper leaf which
nobody knows what to do with anyway but
full Sun it does very very well Coley I
are never going to go away no bill is so
excited we got some saw Salina stemming
okay which is what your coleus work
would call we knew most coleus now
they're all of a sudden a seminar so
that's something they're not even that
any more than all now plectranthus for
what it's worth so there's no such thing
as Cole there's no such thing as salinas
them and now they're all plectranthus
who cares certainly my daughter doesn't
but they're great plants so I Stepan
Newfoundland so we can I mean it's
unbelievable what we can do and I love
there's Hannah and wasabi and here's I
thought this is cool create a little fun
in your in your garden your nursery or
your landscape or whatever this is a
annuals everyone likes wine it's a lady
in Michigan and every plant in there is
a vino dipped in wine Bordeaux sangria
cool that's cool I was cool as you see
she has good parties i want to tell you
so have fun again have fun that's half
the message here know what you're doing
because when people come into your
garden center for example or ask your
advice they don't really want to know
every darn finger you know they just
want to know the best stuff and
the pteros are everywhere this came out
of a ye black coral fantastic alena
fantastic this is up in longwood in
Pennsylvania so not that far different
than you mojito her by lowes mojito it's
love that mojito and this is one that we
put out call Jax giant she's five-foot
not I see what is she she's 5 foot 6 and
so this is a Georgia so we can grow this
great big stuff pretty big as well oh I
gotta go yeah we bring him in or we make
like good landscapers and we'll just let
him die so he can get something new next
year but they do need heat to get going
there's no doubt about it they need to
heat to get going but that whole
tropical look thing you know on how you
do it is up to you I got to go but
certainly ornamental grasses the annual
ornamental grasses for spectacular is
princess and Princess Caroline we did
all these in Georgia prince and princess
the first two introduced and Caroline
and Molly and then proven winners
introduced one of ours as well but this
is probably the most popular one right
now fireworks and I say most popular it
seems to sell them those numbers oh yeah
Oh it'll flower sure it's just it's a
pennisetum of any kind of seasoned flour
is unreal okay I'm going to take a break
from from annuals you can see in my hand
out I got a ton of perennials that
you're just not going to hear about but
some other time I'm going to take a
little trending look at this vegetable
thing too and
I think again when when things were
really rough veggies helped an awful lot
of people people always love vegetables
it used to be that we could say that
women like flowers and men love
vegetables but but that's no longer the
case I think the vegetables are just
everybody wants vegetables today and let
me tell you again that you do not have
to believe a word I say the garden of
tomorrow is the deck and that's where
we're going to be selling vegetables for
we're still going to have vegetable
gardens we're still going to have
tomatoes taller than I am we're still
going to have all that stuff that's not
going to go away but if we're thinking
of getting my neighbor your friends you
know you know you guys if you go look if
you go to a gathering and you're just
talking with neighbors and friends or
whatever and then somebody comes up and
starts talking about plugs and cultivars
you know you turn around and those 10
people that were there it's just you two
left they don't want to hear about this
right so but vegetables everybody wants
vegetables so what are we doing in
vegetables these days this is a major
trend I have absolutely no doubt good
vegetables will keep going you know the
big names are in there okay whether it's
Burpee or whether it's ball or whether
it used to be that you had some seed
veggies now all the major breeders that
we're breeding caliber colas are now
breeding vegetables this is a good thing
because they have the distribution means
to get these out to you the garden
centers now you're still going to buy
your seed for whatever I don't care but
this is an opportunity now for you to
get some of the newer materials that are
coming down easily you know and then you
know on a the places like the burpees in
the balls and the Syngenta's and the
whoever is they going to give you p 0 p
material if you want it and for the
landscapers in the gardener's this is
the information that they're going to
get instead of oil that's a pretty good
tomato I don't know if it has wilt or
not and there's lots of interesting
things going on grafted vegetables now
again I I don't want to believe with
this grafted vegetable thing that
happens to me me and those vegetables
are probably well he'll tall I am those
are my tomatoes last year okay
there's no doubt the grafted vegetables
like the graph the tomatoes grafted I
call this thing it's it's a it's from a
company in California and call ppl and
they're doing everything it's cool and
the nice thing about graft it is you get
a group stock that's much more disease
resistant and much more vigorous to save
a Brandywine tomato that you want it but
you don't get a lot yield you'll get
more yield much more expensive so you
guys in a garden trade in the landscape
trade you might are in the retail trade
might not be able to sell that many
because a tomato myself for 398 and the
cells for 1398 so what who cares it's an
opportunity so you want to get a few in
people are talking about it those are my
tomatoes but I so sort so combo colored
seat offers are happening to like this
multi pellets is a fusible for the
growers in the audience then what we get
is we get a plug that comes into this
wrong way to get this plug that has two
or three seed materials in it different
lettuces different whatever's plunk it
in a thing and now you've got now you've
got this wonderful combination you're
going to see call you're going to see
combinations this afternoon they're
going to knock your socks off of
vegetables and herbs and colorful plants
but this is where we're at i think as
far as this and lots of breeding and
selection for this patio thing this is
our University of Georgia we started
this 10 years ago we started working
with vegetal us and few others to see
what was out there and you know this is
what's happening this may never ever
looked like this in your garden it
doesn't look like that in my garden but
nevertheless these are this is a son of
things that we're looking at or that the
companies are looking at you know grape
type vines on tomatoes and these are
available by the way anybody wants to
try them and if you're a tomato
aficionado give them a go there there
there absolutely available but not just
big things but shorter more prolific
plants and again you're going to see
those this afternoon for the tomato
whether it's neat and sweet or this big
league I think it's wonderful we're
going to see some really cool tomatoes
this afternoon as well they've been bred
for the patio so big fruit small plants
if we can get that
tomatoes by the way there's vegetables
and there's Tomatoes okay I mean truly I
mean it's it's like it's like a whole
different world is I mean when people
ask about vegetables are usually Haskell
tomatoes and if we can go a good tomato
we're doing okay so lots of cool things
happening it seems that everyone a
mental breeder is doing veggies again
this is it i think is syngenta this is
all the Asian vegetables this is from
taki in Japan there praying Asian
vegetables to the consumer actually to
you the garden center or to use a
landscaper so you can put Asian
vegetables in there are new cultivars of
which go very very very strong and our
wonderful the herb tray is exploding for
what it's worth on the app I've just
partnered with the american herb society
and we're going to put herbs on this app
as well because they are exploding so
guys that's this is where these are the
trends there's no doubt about it and i
don't know what to do with this stuff
you tried this little this is Alyssa you
try this it tastes as bad as it looks
this is a hula berries and there's
strawberry times something i'm not sure
what and I they put the note for me I
expect to see those sooo in your place
hula bit anyway it's like it's like
Brazel berries and all these other kind
of things where we're getting fruit in a
container and it's kind of neat so you
might not like it doesn't matter who
cares people talk about it and it's just
that's where we are these are the trends
that are happening and so it's always
fun to see what's going on eggplants big
in containers i think eggplants are
really very very ornamental plants they
truly are there are some eggplants in
Chicago Botanic Garden eggplants with
petunias in our garden so it's just a
real versatile plant and there's
eggplants over here to guard you're
going to see this afternoon but I think
look very good there's white there's
black there's polka-dotted I don't what
you do with an eggplant by truth I can't
think I think am I not a big egg plant
guy but they look nice
they look nice and this was a somebody
in in Ohio who kinda I thought this was
cool they put together towers for
potatoes I want to grow potatoes I don't
have a space so I put together a tower
with with all sorts of soil and pine
straw and whatever and plugged her
tomatoes in our potatoes in and she had
a nice yield the potatoes and also the
same gardener I thought was fantastic
look at these darn things I mean I mean
this is terrific so so people are going
to be a whole lot smarter and I say real
people a lot smaller than we are ok
they're going to do whatever it is
they're going to need to do but you got
to give them the good plants and and so
I think this was really cool and more
power this is Oberlin Ohio and in fact
that person is quite a gardener but you
know working and she got no more time
than you or I do so anyway this is son
of the some of the trends that I'm
seeing with veggies and and and yes
Virginia there really is a ketchup and
fries this is a tomato grafted onto a
potato okay if you haven't seen it and
you don't believe it there's the
potatoes days of tomatoes there's one
again in California looking spectacular
people are talking about ketchup and
fries in fact they sold every catching
and fries or was they sold every single
plant the ppl have done every single
plan are they any good
I got one they are mark says they are
and I got 10 you eat the tomatoes in the
potatoes do the thing and the thing is
it's cool and if you can do it and sell
it more power to you I get one to my
neighbor now my neighbor doesn't do any
burrs your neighbor okay kind of
fighting of gardening I try and give her
some plants and but she's got a young
boy throws a football and all that stuff
doesn't want too much I said look I have
no place for this in my garden can you
take this thing well it got the dog got
the football I got the soccer ball
everything but it's doing okay and it's
produced a lot of small fruit and fruit
are small and I don't know it's going to
get any potatoes it looks like heck
right now but you know that's okay it
looks pretty rough right now it's full
Sun but that's about six feet tall right
now and there's lots of tomatoes on it
and I don't know how the potatoes are
going to do or not so it's cool and I
think if it works mark we do it do I
have to say anymore did you sell grafted
stuff in general you so do you sell
graph the tomatoes how much it before
yeah oh yeah well this is the thing
about this ketchup and fries everybody's
talking about everybody I mean it's in
every magazine on every HDTV talks about
it everybody talks about it so yeah oh
yeah I see no problem whatsoever I I
absolutely i see no problem here in fact
I this this this you can see that the
deck in the shade in the back believe me
lots of beer chips and now tomatoes and
potatoes but if she can do and I say she
can do it she's a young mother and all
that kind of stuff we can all do it so
that was cool yes Virginia there is a
catch oven fries these are some of the
major trends and you know I don't have
time to go through a whole heck of a lot
more so we're going to call it a day
right now but the fact is we got so
many wonderful things at our disposal we
we have the tiger by the tail we just
got to make sure that we don't let it
bite us okay we've got people who are
breeding new plants we got people that
can distribute plants we've got garden
centers like the people in the audience
that can help my daughter and help your
friends we got at all well we got to do
is you say hey we can do it we get I'm
so tired of people saying oh I can't do
this bogus we can do anything absolutely
anything so I say more power to you more
power to us let's have fun and we're
going to see this afternoon and we're
going to have a good time then all right
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu